YouTube faces strong criticism effort
spread conspiracy theories in the
aftermath of the deadly school shooting
in Florida the top trending video on the
platform yesterday falsely accused
survivor David Hogg of being a crisis
actor that video was viewed more than
two hundred thousand times before it was
taken down the YouTube spokesperson said
in a statement quote this video should
never have appeared in trending because
the video contained footage from an
authoritative news source our system
misclassified it this is the second time
this year YouTube has come under fire
for its trending video last month viral
star Logan Paul removed a video he
posted of a suicide victim visi lapowski
is a senior writer at Wired good morning
convenient of YouTube now to say it
never should have been up there but it
ended up becoming the most popular video
on the web site it's no one watching
this well there are people watching this
but there were a few ways that YouTube's
system broke down here basically this
video was a clip of David Hogg speaking
to local news affiliate years ago about
an incident he saw on the beach so
YouTube's algorithms look at that and
say okay this is a legitimate news
source then they look at the caption to
the video the caption said David Hogg
the actor well there's nothing
inherently harassing about those words
for some people that's just a fact for
some people it's a compliment and
YouTube's algorithms don't have all the
context to know that in fact David Hogg
is the survivor of a school shooting
people are unwittingly liking and
sharing what is propaganda exactly so
that really falls to the moderators
YouTube's moderators around the world
and YouTube would say that you know we
have people watching these videos we
have people monitoring the flags but not
everybody has the context about this
specific conspiracy right here in the
United States YouTube is adding
moderators they say they're scaling up
to 10,000 moderators this year but the
question is with 400 hours of video
going up on YouTube every minute could
10,000,000 moderators possibly ever
really vet this stuff and so what I've
been arguing is that you know none of
these trending tools online are really
you know they they don't just exist in
nature these tech companies created them
and they have to start thinking through
is the upside of these tools
you know showing people relevant videos
outweighing the downside which is
showing them sometimes complete
conspiracy theories that are really
harmful so what are the questions that
companies need to be asking right now
because it's so disturbing back to
Nora's point that this video was
trending and people were believing this
in a time of great crisis and pain for
people going through the shooting they
need to think through engagement versus
fact they need to think through what is
the real public service that these
trending tools are are providing they
created them with with good intentions
these are not bad people they created
them because they thought okay if
Facebook if YouTube are the the new way
that people are getting their news today
we can have something akin to the front
page and that becomes this trending
section but if they're unable to police
that because of the sheer volume of
content out there then they have to ask
themselves whether it's responsible to
let these features continue to exist and
quickly is this against YouTube's policy
to have create this kind of video so
recently last year YouTube instituted a
new application of its harassment policy
that said if you do post a hoax video
about the victim of a tragedy we're
gonna consider that harassment it's not
against the rules to post something that
is untrue as we always hear these
companies say they don't want to be the
arbiters of truth but YouTube at least
has decided that if you are playing a
hoax on a victim of a tragedy that's
very clearly harassment all right you
see let me ask you Thanks thank you